the album is coming soon Rihanna is
finally dishing on her new music it's
been over three years since RiRi has
released an album and now in a new
interview with The New York Times Style
magazine she confirmed that she's
working on a reggae album and get this
she reveals it will probably be titled
r9 the working title her fans have given
the record online
she explained quote I'm about to call it
that probably cuz they have haunted me
with this are 9r9 when is r9 coming out
how will I accept another name after
that's been burned into my skull
[Music]
and while Rihanna and Drake have
delivered smashes in the past she says
we shouldn't expect another collab I
don't see it happening
not on this album that's for sure
remember if things have been kinda
awkward between them since he tried to
kiss her at the 2016 MTV VMAs now back
to the music please as for a release
date well she says the album doesn't
have one yet in the meantime Rihanna is
busy with Fenty her new fashion house
launched in collaboration with LVMH the
new gig makes her the first black woman
in history to run a major luxury fashion
house in Paris she told the mag quote I
don't know if it makes people
uncomfortable or not but that's not even
my business you know I do know that the
reason I'm here is not because I'm black
it's because of what I have to offer
that's what they're invested in and the
fact that I'm black is just that a fact
but this isn't the first brand Rihanna
has headed guys the limit no rules I can
do whatever I want the singer has a
successful lingerie brand as well as a
collaboration with Puma and a cosmetics
line Fenty beauty all women deserve to
feel beautiful and all women deserve to
have a choice and an option when they go
to the makeup counter women love makeup
and they should all be included et
caught up with RiRi backstage at the
savage by Fenty fashion show in 2018
where she opened up about wanting to
create something sexy for every woman I
wanted to do something that was special
and new and different a unique
I think you managed to kind of
accomplish that I think women's bodies
are designed so differently uniquely
that they should just do what makes them
feel best and sexiest
[Music]
[Applause]